In this case
depends very much on the position you are applying to,
that is,
there are different roles in the kitchen.
Wow, so
you have those who are like kitchen assistants,
those who are in charge of a specific area
or some special meal,
Not the chefs and everything?
Then
It depends on why they hire you.
If you are hired
it is very strange that you are hired for something else.
other than the kitchen assistant
and so they all earn the same at the beginning.
But uh,
a way you can apply
in a way
to pay you more and not pay so little
as is the case for the first year,
is for you to contact the camp directly,
with the camp you contact and send your curriculum,
you have your interviews and if you are hired
now you do apply with the agency.
That's another way and there like this
you would be practically hired
direct to the camp
and they pay you more than
if you do everything from the beginning with the agency.
Then
I also recommend that you try to search for
Internet camps and send your curriculum,
have your interviews
and then apply with the agency.
If you have any further doubts about this,
please let me know.
and I can answer it for you
or you can send me a message
and I answer faster
I've been making videos,
sorry